good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-2000 checked
class Keter special containment
procedures samples of SCP 20 yard in a
series of sealed cultivation chambers
inside a sealed containment room at
biological research area 12 which is
accessible only via airlock nutrients
are administered via automated robotic
systems as the cultivation chamber must
remain sealed at all times hermetically
sealed video surveillance cameras are
installed within the containment room
and must be checked daily for integrity
any personnel entering the containment
room must wear biosafety level 5
equipment including rebreathers and
undergo full antifungal disinfection
upon exiting description SCP 20 is a
fast spreading fungal organism that is
capable of affecting the senses and
behavior of living creatures including
humans samples of a-c-p 20 exhibit an
unknown effect that renders them
effectively invisible to direct
observation even when under a microscope
SCP 20 is only visible to humans when
viewed through photographic or video
surveillance once scp-2401 that affect
the behavior of humans around it
affected subjects will increase the heat
and humidity within their homes to
create an environment more suitable to
the growth of SCP 20
affected subjects also become more
sociable in many cases and often invite
acquaintances to their homes to further
spread the organism as the spores and
mold colonies are invisible to affected
subjects the mold will sometimes grow
directly on living subjects as the
spores and colonies within a home
approach critical concentration the
health of affected human subjects will
rapidly deteriorate resulting in death
further spread of the mold may occur as
the bodies of any deceased subjects are
encountered by emergency responders and
health care agents as well as
transportation of the bodies to local
morgues SCP 21 count erdan where an
undercover SCP agent noted dramatic
personality changes in personnel working
at the local hospital upon investigation
by a containment team it was discovered
that almost civilians had been infected
as well as the majority of the town the
civilian population was terminated and
the town incinerated under cover of a
local flash forest fire
to date over 12 outbreaks of SCP 24 'td
investigations are currently underway to
determine the source of these outbreaks
and possible preventive measures
addendum 2001 excerpts from the
audio-video mission recorders of mobile
task force eta 10 see no evil
during the initial containment of SCP
2002 moving to the red house easy one is
picking up one-eighth signature doing
place ready to door opening at this
point a civilian woman appeared in the
doorway holding a kitchen knife video
surveillance to show that nearly
two-thirds of her face was covered by
mold grows on the ground
drop the weapon stop where you are
drop the weapon come in it is assumed at
this point the infected civilian notice
t-to carrying a primed incendiary weapon
and lost four other team members
okay thank you for listening even though
this was a short lecture and you were
all dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Jim's Saba Maximus Decimus arbiter
Sewell
dr. bright darius time Justin day turn
armed agents Nider Joker Corvis and
jayvo Jack Corey Barker and Aronian
thank you all so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well visit patreon.com forward
slash the volgin thank you
you